[music playing]
She's not even holding
an equilibrium there.
Let's just give
her a few minutes.
[water splashing lightly]
But she's definitely waking up.
I think it's going to
be worth releasing.
That's good.
Send her up river.
I'm glad we did that.
She deserved it.
[engine starting]
Well, let's go
check our other net.
Maybe we can find a male
that we can eat tonight.
There's definitely
debris in this one as well.
Here we go again.
Oh, here's one right here.
Oh!
Looks like we're
catching fish.
There he is.
Think that's a male?
Yep.
Something to eat.
Oh, there's one here.
We've got two nice ones there.
That's payoff
for conservation.
[chuckles]
I got something
heavy here, a live one.
Oh, that's a big one.
Oh, is that male?
Yeah.
Yay.
A little bit of driftwood
and three nice keeper fish.
I'm glad that we don't
have a net full of fish
because that is more
than we would need.
And we don't want to overfish.
That's perfect for what
that species can give to us.
Look who came.
Hi--
Hi, Dickel.
--Dickel.
Yay.
He says, you guys
cooking some salmon for me?
Good boy, Dickel.
Dickel's been a great
dog, and I think about all
the great times I had with
him, all the adventures
we've shared together.
And I'd celebrate
that, not the fact
that it might be the last couple
of weeks or the last month.
That is delicious.
It's pretty hard to be
too much fresher than that.
You know what I think
makes it really taste
good is knowing that
there is one that
was released out of it today.
I'm very proud
of the fact that I
was able to release
a female king salmon
to go up and finish spawning.
This life has provided a
really, really good life for me.
And I just want other people
to have the opportunity
to experience that.
Cheers.
[mimics clinking]
Oh, that's so good.
[music playing]